democracy is such an interesting subject
at the moment isn't it
you know we're seeing countries in
Europe in former Central and Eastern
Europe starting to Teeter a little and
Turkey as well and then of course Putin
thinks he got himself re-elected and I'm
sure we've all been asking how
democratic that process was so I think
it's a really topical and a really
interesting subject and let me introduce
the guests here on my right is Nick
Cheeseman and he is professor of
democracy at the University of
Birmingham and the author of how to rig
an election so I hope you'll tell us a
bit about the Hat on my near left here
is Yasmin alibi Brown former colleague
of mine at the independence and I writes
a column for a newspaper and on my far
left literally is Natalie Bennett who of
course is a former leader the Green
Party and former editor of Guardian
weekly so I'm gonna start with you Nick
so my pitch to you is that the problem
of democracy is actually that democracy
is one of the easiest forms of political
system to kind of hollow out from the
inside and as you said I've got a book
that's just come out called how to rig
an election when we started doing the
research for that book we thought we
were going to find relatively
significant problematic levels of
electoral manipulation around the world
but sort of 2025 percent what we
actually found is really striking its
Thunders we're talking about something
like every other election that is being
held in the world today having
significant manipulation of one kind or
another we're talking about elections
that on average are such poor quality in
some parts of the world that we're
actually seeing the opposition when only
one in ten elections that are organized
in other words elections that have
effectively stopped challenging
authoritarians
challenging poor leaders kicking the
bums out but actually served to
legitimate the existing distribution of
power those fantastic stories that we
find in the book of the way these
elections are being manipulated a great
one is from Madagascar where Marlo
Ravalomanana who's a very sort of famous
leader in the country a yogurt magnate
made his money in dairy he wanted to win
the election easily his opposition
leader was outside of the country he
decided that the best way to stop him
I'm actually competing in the election
was simply that every time he was flying
to the country keep in mind it's an
island he closed all of the airports
unilaterally right the guy never managed
to get into the country he couldn't
submit his papers he wasn't on the
ballot paper the election on the day was
pretty good quality why because you
don't need to worry about the election
on the day if you've excluded you're
most likely rival so on the day the
election was pretty free and fair what
happened international observers decided
that the election was good enough to get
a rubber stamp Ravalomanana not only
retained the presidency but with the
support of the international community
so my pitch here is the problem is not
so much democracy but that we have
allowed democracy to be hollowed out of
meaning and it's not just that this is
happening in far-flung tin-pot
dictatorships that you might think about
in other parts of the world
post-communist Europe sub-saharan Africa
Asia Latin America where recently for
example we could talk about the rigging
of the election in Venezuela it's not
just that democracy is being hollowed
out in those places it's also at risk of
being hollowed out in the United States
and the United Kingdom as well
the classic example in the United States
is it as many of you will know we have
seen massive processes of gerrymandering
whereby essentially leaders get to pick
who votes for them rather than the other
way around
in other words we see places in the
United States where we actually get
people who are able to actually select
the people voting for them by
distributing constituency boundaries in
that way and what that means is that we
actually see an awful lot of elections
both in the UK in the US that are
effectively uncompetitive excluding
large portions of the electorate from
the political process so my argument is
that we don't need to abandon democracy
but we need a process of democratic
renewal thank you and brilliantly on
time
I'm gonna go to Natalie next and then
Yasmine okay well I'm going to begin
with a thesis that you might find a
little bit shocking Britain is not a
democracy in the last election
sixty-eight percent of votes didn't
count that's from the electoral reform
Society you can look at their report
twenty percent of people were voting
tactically voting for a party that they
didn't want but they thought that might
stop some other party they didn't want
more people don't have a free choice and
if you go back to the 2015 election the
Tories won a hundred percent of the
power with the support of twenty four
percent of eligible voters now where
perhaps we might have some conflict on
this panel and I perhaps have a little
bone to pick with Nik is that I think
it's really dangerous to say that
democracy is failing
and this is a very common narrative
actually was in Sheffield a few days ago
was just talking to an ordinary voter in
the street and he said to me oh well you
know after brick said after Trump I
really don't democracy it's just failed
and I may have slightly jumped down his
throat more than I should have and said
well let's try democracy before we give
up on it
Trump of course is another great example
Hillary Clinton won the popular vote by
any normal standard she won the election
and Trump ended up as president I was in
Sheffield doing a debate against the
American professor had written this book
called against democracy and his thesis
was basically you know it's failed so we
have to give up on it and we kind of
need a mirror topic meritocratic
oligarchy to decide things in other
words people like me should decide how
to run the country well I would say if
you look around the world if you look at
the most democratic countries actually
it's the Scandinavian countries that
abroad to the most democratic and
they're also by far by most people's
measures the best countries in the world
to live in the best working countries
and if you take the most extreme example
of all perhaps which is Iceland now
Iceland
population about the size of Sheffield's
population Iceland has a prime minister
a president 64 members of parliament it
also has about 50 local government areas
roughly comparable to our councils and
those areas are actually guaranteed
autonomy in the National Constitution
they have a written constitution there
might be something of a hint for us in
that there and they have control of
local transport local schools so I would
argue that actually what we need is
vastly more democracy in Britain we
don't have democracy now let's introduce
democracy and you know Marianne perhaps
we're going to disagree on this but I'm
also I suspect it might be controversial
with this audience but I'm also going to
defend absolutely the idea of
referendums good referendums well
conducted referendums not like the one
we had in 2016 but I believe in trusting
the people I believe in democracy and I
think we should try it around the world
and we shouldn't be talking about it
failing we should be saying
let's try it let's do it let's follow
the people who've made it work yes when
I kind of almost totally agree with what
an accept but I want to go a bit further
because I am really heartily sick of
being accused of being against democracy
against the will of the people every
time I open my mouth because and I do
completely disagree with Natalie on the
referendum point but we'll come to that
because one of the things that's
happened in this country and I don't
know why whether we stopped citizenship
education whether we didn't think enough
about it there's been free education
here since 1944 how was it possible for
so many people how is it possible for so
many people to be lied to so many times
in the name of democracy and that
worries me a lot actually right that how
are people convinced of things that were
paitent lee lies during the referendum
and often are during elections and also
not understanding demo
she's not your vote on one day every
five years which is then counted the
whole structure is a fragile structure
and I do agree that's been hollowed out
because if you look at democracy in that
way we are talking about Hitler being
elected we are talking about the Mugabe
form of democracy we're talking about
these councils all across Pakistan and
Afghanistan of men and women these days
who decide what will happen in a mini
form of referendum and they come up with
the worst most inhumane policies
possible and they say this was the will
of the people so I think we need to kind
of communicate better all of us that the
essential ingredients of a good working
democracy freedom to debate freedom to
change your mind not license to degrade
and and disempower and oppress not
majorities and majority nism I do not
say it majoritarianism majoritarianism
because really good democracies have
space and protection for minorities not
nativism this is my country now and fair
policies for the protection of the human
rights of everybody so it again in
Turkey one of my the countries I loved
most because I thought then look it's
possible to be a Muslim which I am and a
secular Democrat once upon a time he
used democracy to kill secular democracy
[Applause]